[Music]  hello there now i know what you're  thinking crikey a black cat he's gonna  bring me bad luck  shows what you know about luck  let's drop some knowledge  luck is different all around the world  like in scotland but a black cat like me  is considered very lucky remember kids  don't try this at home  name's bob by the way and this is the  land of luck  morning jerry  we work behind the scenes to create  those wee lucky and unlucky moments that  make up your everyday life  like these guys an entire team thinking  up the jammy luck that kind that makes  you feel like a million bucks  okay maybe a hundred bucks of course  then there's the other team  working on the not so jammy kind of luck  and they sure love what they do  well you humans are a complicated lot  and that's why things run so smoothly  here because no human has ever stepped  foot in this place and with a little bit  of luck they never will  uh  where am i  oh you gotta be kidding  [Music]  ugh  [Music]  you